Boyd: My name's Ryan Boyd
and I'm here today
to talk to you
about powering mobile apps
with social data.
All of you--and this
was going to be probably
have something like this.
Now I think it's you all have
something like this
where you use a mobile device
that has internet access
and you probably use it
every single day
as much if not more than you use
your actual computer.
We're going to talk
in this session
a little bit about
how you can take the social data
that you have defined
out there on the web
and pull it in and use it
on a mobile device
to make applications
more powerful.
To start off,
a little number here.
This shocked me.
Last year, there were
140 million smartphones sold
throughout the world.
Uh, that breaks down
into something like half
are Symbian devices.
Uh, then it goes to,
uh, Blackberries,
and Windows Mobile,
and iPhones, and--and all.
And, um, also a bunch
of Android devices.
But there's a huge audience
out there
for any mobile app
that you develop.
Uh, and depending
on the type of app
that you develop,
which we'll go into later,
uh, the audience size
differs.
Uh, but think about that.
140 million devices
were sold last year.
And these are smartphones
which, you know,
I'm presuming most of them
have access to the internet.
So the agenda.
How are we gonna spend
our time here today?
We're going to talk a little bit
about the technology,
choosing the right type
of application to build,
uh, for your use case,
how it all fits together
with authorization
and the protocols,
and then dive into some examples
and code.
Uh, and then we're going
to talk a little bit
about the future.
Uh, and hopefully the future
comes true.
Um, and then take some questions
and answers.
On that first slide here--
I'll actually step back.
It's probably bad
to do this.
But I'll step back.
Uh, on this first slide here,
there's a URL
for any questions
that you have during this talk.
Uh, there--you can ask them
on Moderator at that URL
or, uh, at the end
of the session,
you can come up
to the microphones
and ask your questions
in person
if you're not terribly shy.
You can also post
your feedback for this talk
at the URL at the bottom.
All right.
So every app is better when...
Anyone have any answer
for me?
Social. Yes. Good answer.
Uh, I-I did this
in a rehearsal
and someone told me
"it's mobile."
I guess that also applies
for this session
pretty well too.
But think about it.
Weather is something
that you probably talk
to a bunch of people
every day about
in sort of small talk
conversations.
Somewhat meaningless
Just a way to--to start off
and get to know someone.
Weather is also something
that you may care about
for your close family
and friends.
I know I do.
Like, I-I keep track
of, uh, in my mobile device,
I keep track of the list
of, like, zip codes
or locations
of--of where my family
and friends are located.
And, um, then I look
at the weather.
So I look at the weather
and say, you know what,
um, sorry, mom,
I know, you know,
you're experiencing 20 degrees
temperatures
and, uh, lots of snowfall
there in Pennsylvania.
And I'm here
in sunny California.
It's, you know,
only 60 degrees.
Uh, or it's--
it's up to 60 degrees.
Um, so, you know, it just
creates some conversation.
And the one thing
that I'm really missing
right now though
is the ability to keep track
of my friends and family
who are often traveling.
So, you know,
if I have a friend
that's visiting D.C.
in the fa--
or lives in D.C.
and it's fall there,
um, I might be looking
at the weather in D.C.
when in fact
they're in San Francisco
and experiencing the fog.
Or I have a friend
that, uh, you know,
normally lives in New York
and it's really ugly.
And in fact,
they can make fun of me
and say that they're,
you know,
sitting in Trunk Bay
enjoying
the beautiful Caribbean.
Um, so think about how you can
make weather social.
It's not something--
you know, we do chitchat.
But you don't--haven't seen
any social apps out there--
I haven't--uh, that make
the weather as social
as it could be.
Exercise and weight loss.
You know, you're going to think,
"hey, that's something
that's ordinarily very private."
How many calories
you ate today
or, you know, how much weight
you've lost.
You might, you know,
talk about that
with your closest friends.
Uh, but you're, you know,
really not broadcasting it out
to a larger group
of friends.
However, these types of things
can also be very social.
Uh, I know a bunch
of people that I work with
and friends and family
that use, uh, an app
on the iPhone that allows you
to keep track
of the calories
that you're eating.
You put in, you know,
your exercise that you did
and your calorie intake
and it computes, like,
how much weight you can lose
and that sort of thing--
with some other information
like age and that sort.
Um, but, you know,
this information
just stays there
on your personal device.
And then you go and you talk
to your friends
and say, you know,
"what did you do today?"
or, you know,
"how's it going?"
But wouldn't it be
much better
if you could actually have
a graph of that information
and be able to, you know,
compete against your friends?
And have--you know,
not only can you compete
in games and such,
but you can compete
in real life.
Uh, hopefully
in a healthy way.
Hopefully you're doing
the working out at the gym,
uh, and eating
the fresh fruit,
and, uh, not doing other things
to lose weight.
But, um, you know,
so that's something
that can also
be made social.
So here's a list
of a bunch of other ideas.
I'm not going to go
into each of these.
But I encourage you all,
um, to think about them
and think about how
they can be social.
Um, and, you know, we have
a couple different types though
of social apps.
Uh, you can build
a social app
that just sits inside
a social network,
uh, you know, using something
like MySpace or hi5
or--or other social networks
out there.
Or you can build
a, uh, social app
that just sits
on a mobile device
and interacts
with these networks.
Or you can take
your social network app
that sits, uh, normally
inside of MySpace
and you can actually build
a mobile version of it.
And we've seen a number
of providers do that,
uh, Cingular cetera.
But what's the technology
which enables all of this?
Uh, I'm going to be stressing,
you know,
things like OpenSocial
here today.
Although they do--
you know, all of this does apply
to other technologies.
Uh, but OpenSocial introduced
in version 0.8.1
REST and RPC protocols.
Uh, these REST and RPC protocols
allow a standard way
to access social data
on a wide variety
of social networks.
For those of you
that aren't familiar with it,
there are about 25 or more
social networks around the world
that support OpenSocial.
Uh, those all have
the capability of exposing data
with these REST
and RPC protocols.
I'll have a slide here later,
which shows the current ones
which do.
Um, but anyway, in addition
to the OpenSocial standard,
we also use the OAuth standard
for authorizing access
to this social data.
Uh, these networks want
to make sure
that the user has consented
to giving you that information
for your application.
And then
there are client libraries
that instead of using the raw
XML and HTTP or JSON data,
uh, you can use
these client libraries
written in a variety
of languages,
uh, in order to make
your applications
a little bit faster.
And then we have
some sample code,
uh, for both Android devices
and the iPhones.
But don't forget the idea
that the web is really
what powers all of this.
Uh, you know,
all these technologies
sit on top of the web,
uh, and make this--
this possible.
So choosing the right road.
Uh, make sure you don't
go down the--the wrong way
and hit the bicyclist
in this picture.
But--so choosing the right road
to success.
You can build
a web application.
You can build a web application
with some native functionality
that hooks
into, uh, the device's
native functionality
like geolocation
and things like that
using HTML 5 and Gears.
Or you can just build
a-a purely native application
that has access
to the full suite of APIs
on a native device.
So web application.
Single app.
You're developing
a single application
which deploy--you know,
is able to be viewed
on pretty much most of those
140 million devices
that were sold last year.
You can use open standards.
Open standards such as HTML.
Or for a lot of devices,
things like JavaScript
and CSS as well.
But it's not available,
typically,
in a market or app store.
Although some applications
have taken their web apps
and, uh, kind of built
a layer around it
using something
like the WebView in Android
to, you know, give a native
application framework
around the mobile web app.
But that's not that popular
and users don't really expect
those types of applications
to be in a market or app store.
You can also build
a web application
with some native
functionality.
You can have improved
performance
over standard web apps
and it can be made available
offline
depending on the technologies
you're using.
And you can also have access
to native APIs
such as geolocation.
These standards
are still emerging.
Um, right now you may need
to fork a little bit
for different, uh, platforms.
So if you want to do
some of the offline stuff,
you know, you might use Gears
on one device or HTML 5,
at app cache databases
and things like that
on other devices.
So a native application.
Basically, you get
the higher performance.
You get access
to the full suite of APIs.
You can still call the web
when you need to.
And it requires building
an app for each platform.
So you may have to learn Java,
and Objective-C, and C++ APIs,
and, you know, know every
programming language out there.
But you can take advantage
of--of those other features
of native applications.
So we're going to start off
by talking
about web applications.
Um, and, you know,
basically, we built a couple,
little different samples
for this presentation.
Um, the first one
I'm going to talk about
is the "what you doing?" app.
Uh, and "what you doing?" app
is--is kind of a--
a dumbed down version
of the next app
we'll talk about.
But basically what it is
is an application that you go,
you log in to a particular
social network--
any of them that supports,
uh, these REST and RPC APIs,
and what's called
three-legged OAuth,
which I'll dive into later--
and you go and, uh, you choose
the network.
You hit "log in."
For some reason,
that video on the left
always pauses,
um, in presentation mode
with these projectors,
but not in the other things--
projectors that I've used.
So forgive that.
But the left, uh, Android app
is doing the exact same thing
on, uh, this web application.
And you go and log in.
And basically,
you can see the updates
everyone has made.
Uh, you can see updates
from particular friends.
And you can post
a little status update.
It's very simple,
uh, standard application,
uh, that just uses JavaScript
and HTML.
And this should work
across many different devices
around the world.
So how does this work?
Here's the--the different actors
in play here.
We have the mobile device.
We have MySpaceID
and MySpace's social data,
uh, using OAuth
and the OpenSocial APIs.
And then we have an App Engine
back-end.
Uh, this application
is built with Java,
uh, as an App Engine
application.
Um, and then we go
and we have the communication
that we're doing here.
So first off, the mobile device
communicates over to MySpace
to get a request token
for OAuth
and then hands over the flow
to the App Engine app
to store that authorization
for access
to someone's social data.
And then the mobile device
uses JSON.
Um, if you can believe it
or not,
that's actually the logo
for JSON.
I didn't know it too
till I went
to do this presentation.
But it then uses JSON
to talk to the App Engine app,
uh, and say
"give me the list of friends
"so that I can display
the status updates
from only the user's friends."
Uh, and then the App Engine app
in the back-end
uses the OpenSocial APIs
to talk over to MySpace
and, uh, get that social data.
And then the App Engine app
can cache it
for a period of time,
uh, usually defined
by the policies
of the social networks.
So here's the JavaScript code.
Basically, there's two methods
which are important here,
one called "getRecentUpdates"
and another called
"getFriendUpdates."
Uh, and just builds out
the two screens
in that app
with the various updates.
"getFriendUpdates"
is being filtered
by, uh, your friends.
So these are JavaScript calls
that end up going off
to the App Engine back-end.
And the App Engine back-end
has two major classes.
Uh, one is an update,
which represents,
uh, the list of updates
including the posting time
and the content,
uh, as well as the OpenSocial ID
of the author.
Uh, and then a user class,
which represents that ID
as well as what social network
they're connected to.
So on the social code side,
um, this is basically
the code that's being used,
uh, using the Java
client library for OpenSocial.
And we're just doing
some setup here.
Um, and a large part--
basically,
this whole first slide,
uh, with the exception
of the last line,
is just setting up
your access
to the social data.
This is setting up the OAuth
consumerKey and consumerSecret,
which identifies
your application
to the social network.
And then it's setting up
the Access Token Secret,
which shows that you have access
to that particular user's
social data.
And then the last line
is the only line here
that's really doing something
substantial.
And that's basically saying
"OpenSocial client,
"fetch the friends
of the currently
authenticated user.
Uh, and it's really
simple data.
And the only data
that you need here really
is the ID of the user.
Uh, in other applications,
which we'll demonstrate
later on,
you also use, like,
the thumbnail
for the, uh,
for the profile picture.
But this shows you
the basic code here.
And now we're going
to enhance it
and, uh, demo what's called
the "where you at?" application,
uh, which is the last
application,
but enhanced with a little bit
of native functionality.
So we're going to go,
and on the Android device here,
uh, load up the application.
And, um, I apologize
if my network connection
was a little weak
at the time
that I took
this screencast here.
But I went in and say,
um, now I can see a map.
Uh, that map plots out
the points
at which all my friends
made their updates.
Um, and I can go log in
on any social network here
that I'm choosing.
And after I log in,
I can post and update myself.
And you can see me
doing that here.
But first I need to do
the OAuth authorization.
I'll dive into the details
of OAuth a little bit later.
But I really wanted to cover
the social aspects first.
So after I visit
the OAuth flow
and authorize access
to my data,
I come back
to the application.
And wait for it here.
[laughs]
And it displays the map,
uh, with all the updates.
And I can go and click
on friends--
uh, the little friend
link there
and see the updates
just from my friends.
Uh, and you can see the list
of textual updates
was also filtered
based off of my friends.
And now I can go here
and also post an update.
And it will include the location
of where I'm currently at,
uh, at the time that I-I posted
this update.
And all my friends
will be able to see that.
So that's taking the basic
web application
with HTML and JavaScript,
uh, front-end
and a Java App Engine
back-end,
and adding some native
functionality
from the mobile device.
It uses the Gears,
um, libraries
to get the location
from the device,
uh, and post that
up to the container.
And it allows my friends
to see it.
So we added just a few little,
uh, functions
in the JavaScript code
for this application
to enable this native
functionality.
Uh, we watch the position
using Google Gears.
Keep track of the position
where the user's at.
Uh, and we then use
getNearbyUpdates
to retrieve the updates
that are near my position
uh, where I'm currently at
either based off of GPS,
or IP geolocation,
or Wi-Fi geolocation.
And then we update the position
when we post an update.
So next I'm going to talk
about a purely native app.
Uh, this app is called
Divide and Conquer.
And basically what it is
is an open source application
that's already out there
written by another developer,
um, which is
the Divide and Conquer game.
But I extended that with a bit
of social functionality.
Uh, primarily
a social scoreboard.
So I'm going to go
on my Android device.
Click here.
Click "new game."
I'm going to go around
and play the game a little bit.
I'm actually going to control
the video here
so you don't have to watch me
playing for too long.
But basically,
the objective of--of this
is to divide off the ball
into the 20%
of the area of the screen,
at which point you advance
to the next level.
However, you lose a life
if the ball hits a line,
uh, as it's being drawn.
So I'm going to go through here
and get to level three.
And then I hit the--
hit the line
and comes up
a social scoreboard.
So before this game added
a social functionality,
basically, you kept on having
the incentive,
uh, over and over
to score to the next level,
but you had no way
to share that information
with your friends
or compete against your friends
without, like, making
a phone call,
or sending a text,
or posting to a network
"hey, I just scored this.
What did you score?"
In this case
in the social scoreboard,
we actually, uh, have a global
top score list
from not just your friends
but anyone that's used
this application
and may have signed in
using a variety
of different social networks
that all support
the OpenSocial APIs.
Um, and then at the bottom
was, um, the--
your actual friends,
and their profile pictures,
and what their top score is.
So now I'm going to go
a little bit into the code
and how this works.
But first,
uh, here's the data flowing.
So again, here's the actors,
uh, in this application.
We have the Android device,
uh, which is,
you know, it's an Android
native application,
so it's specifically
an Android device in this case.
Uh, and again, I'm using
MySpaceID and MySpace
for the social data
and access to the social data.
And then I'm using
a App Engine back-end.
In this case,
it's a Python-based
App Engine back-end.
Um, and, you know,
just to make sure
you're all aware,
I wasn't forced
to use App Engine for this.
Honestly, it was just
the easiest way
I could get this application
done very quickly.
There's some great samples
online,
which allow you to do JSON,
uh, RPC-based web services,
uh, with App Engine.
So we're going
to start off here.
Uh, the Android device
calls out to MySpace
and gets an OAuth
request token.
Um, and the user
gets redirected
in that browser flow
that we'll go
into more detail later.
Then uses the OpenSocial APIs
directly from the Android device
to go out and get the list
of my friends
and get their profile URL--
their thumbnail URLs
and retrieve
their thumbnail data.
And then when the game is over--
again using that JSON logo--
uh, when the game is over,
uh, it basically makes
a JSON RPC request
and says
"hey, here's my current score,"
um, and let's that update.
But in the background
this entire time,
it's also getting data,
um, on the top score list,
and getting the data
of your friends,
and, um, gathering
their top scores
in a background process
so that when you get
to the end of the game,
uh, you're not stuck
with waiting
for this all to happen.
So here's a little difference,
uh, comparison
between the two architectures
for the web app
and the native app.
Um, and basically,
the differences here
in the applications
that I've built--
and you can do these
different ways--
Uh, in the applications
that I've built,
the main difference is that,
uh, in the native app,
you're accessing the social data
from MySpace directly
on the device,
uh, using the Java OpenSocial
client libraries.
And the web application,
you're accessing the social data
from a App Engine application
and caching it there.
Um, but with your native app,
you could actually, you know,
have the same social data
be accessed
from the App Engine back-end
as long as you found a way
to relay that OAuth token
over to App Engine.
So we're going to dive in to it
a little bit, the code here.
DivideAndConquerActivity.
Uh, for those of you
familiar
with Android application
development,
activities are, like,
kind of the main units
in Android.
And the DivideAndConquerActivity
was the existing class,
which already existed--
existing class
that already existed,
that's kind of redundant there.
But anyway,
it was the existing class
that was the open source class
that controlled
much of the gameplay.
And basically what we did then
is add to this class
some functionality
to collect your top scores,
collect how long it took you,
uh, to achieve those scores,
and, uh, then display
the TopScoresDialog.
But first we had to choose
which social network,
uh, that you're going
to connect to.
I didn't show that yet.
Again, I'm going to dive
into the OAuth stuff later.
But, uh, and then we have
this social handler
which controls the access
to the social data,
connects over to MySpace,
retrieves the social data,
um, and brings that back
to the device.
And this all happens
in the background
in a thread, uh, to avoid
the performance problems
I was talking about
where you reach
the end of the game
and have to wait a while.
And then there's finally
the TopScoresDialog,
which is that, you know,
visual display
of the information and its UI.
And frankly, that's the part
that I spent the longest on
was just trying to get the UI
to be how I liked.
So the back-end code,
uh, I mentioned the JSON
RPC sample code that's out there
for App Engine.
The back-end code, uh,
has one main method post.
And then for each
of the HTTP post requests,
it can go off and call
a particular RPC method.
And there's three methods
defined here.
Get the global top scores,
get the top scores for friends,
and set my score.
And the SetScore method,
basically,
all of these APIs I have
is open.
I don't really authenticate
access to these APIs
for the App Engine app.
So, yes, in theory,
you could fake, uh, your scores
in this app.
Maybe I'll--I'll figure out
a way to let it, uh, be
so you can't fake your scores.
But anyway, when you go off
and you set your score,
you basically say
"here's my current score."
And the device
doesn't keep track
of all your past history.
It just keeps track
of your current score.
And then on the server side,
it says "hey,
was that top score--
"or was that score
your best score yet
in this application?"
And if so, it stores it.
If not, it just drops it.
So step by step.
We have the mobile app.
We go into it.
We go in and choose
our social network.
And you'll see
that video later.
Uh, and after we choose
our social network,
we go over to authorize access
to our social data.
In this case,
I'm using Google.
But in the demos that I showed,
uh, some of it was MySpace.
Works the same way
either way.
Comes back to the game
and then it runs
that background process.
And then when you're dead,
it displays
the top score list.
But in the end,
that's really our goal
is to display
this top score list
and increase
some competitiveness
within the game.
Increase the amount of time
people are playing the game.
So the background stuff
that's happening,
um, getting the top score list,
is basically--
this is the JSON RPC stuff.
Um, we have a single argument
that I add here
and say "getTopScores."
And then I call over to my HTTP
back--or App Engine back-end,
um, and call that RPC method.
I get some JSON data back.
Although I don't show
how I parse that JSON data
in these slides.
Getting self and friends,
uh, again, also happens
in the background.
It basically sets up
all the identity stuff.
And...
then goes and fetches friends
and fetches the current person
authenticated.
Basically, I fetched
the current person
'cause that's the way
I get the ID.
So the OAuth token,
which I got back
after the whole OAuth flow,
gives me access.
And then I go off
to the container.
It says--it'll say who--
"what's the ID for this user?"
And it's an OpenSocial ID
on a particular container.
Uh, but I need to know that
in order to keep track
of my top scores.
But I also need
to know my friends.
I'm making these
as two separate calls here.
Um, as a caveat,
if you were doing this
in a real production
application,
you might want to actually
do this as a batch call.
OpenSocial supports
the concept of batching
multiple requests together.
And that would be a little bit
more efficient.
So after I fetch my friends
and fetch--
fetch the individual,
uh, people,
I then go through and put stuff
in a return hash table.
But, uh, that's not
that important for this.
So then we get the top scores
of our friends.
Uh, and again,
one simple line here difference
between this and the last code
and that's basically
the different, um, uh, argument
than it's specifying
for the RPC score.
But then after I get it,
I then need
to get the pictures
for each of those people.
So what I do is I have
the friend object,
which in the Java client library
is an OpenSocial person object.
And I'm looping through
each of the people
that I retrieve back
as friends
and getting
their thumbnail URL.
And if they were
in the top score list,
then I retrieve that thumbnail
from the server
and put the location
of that file
on the Android device
into a hash table
for later access
when we display
the top score list.
But before we display
the top score list,
we actually have to set
our score
and that's what it's doing.
Again just doing
one simple argument
saying the RPC method
we're calling,
setting the level,
and the time taken,
as well as the name.
So because we can display
that global top score list
and any of the users
who are using this application
can come from a variety
of different social networks,
I won't always have access
to say "given this ID,
what's their name?"
so I store that name
at the time
that the person stor--
or gets their top score.
So I bounced over this
a little bit here,
the OAuth authorization,
because I really wanted to talk
about the social stuff first.
But now
let's get into a little bit
about how the OAuth
authorization
enables us to get access
to use this data.
There's a lot of words
in these slides.
These slides will be available
online later.
But basically,
OAuth is a standard
that's used across
many different APIs.
Uh, in this case,
almost all the OpenSocial
containers
in one way or the other
use OAuth.
Um, and it enables
the containers or APIs
to authenticate
and authorize users
how they wish.
So basically it's all about
a flow to a web page.
Uh, it's not about actually
getting a username
and password.
So it's a flow to a web page
where the user generally
would enter their username
and password directly
on that web page,
but not give it to the actual
application author.
Uh, and there's two
different types.
There's this two-legged,
which is the newer way,
and there's a three-legged,
uh, which is
that web browser flow.
I'll go into the types here
in the next slide.
But, uh, first some caveats,
which I'll go into detail on.
But basically, installed apps
have no way
to really identify themselves
securely.
There's those consumer keys
and secrets.
And those are transmitted,
um, over the wire
in your installed app
when the user downloads the app.
So there's some things
that we're doing
to get around that
or at least mitigate that.
Um, and then it requires
the web browser
for the authorization flow,
which some application
developers or UI designers
may not be used to.
So the types, uh,
I mentioned three-legged OAuth
and two-legged OAuth.
Three-legged
is what you're seeing
in all the examples
that I'm using here today.
And basically, the idea
behind three-legged
is there may not be
an actual application
that sits inside
a social network.
Uh, in this case,
my applications
have no corresponding app
that sits in MySpace
or hi5 or whatever.
Um, but basically it allows you
to redirect.
And the user can grant access,
uh, usually on a forever basis
until revoked,
uh, to their social data.
And revocation can happen
depending on how the container
wishes to implement it.
Uh, and usually
that would be implemented
in a settings control panel
under your account
where you can choose,
uh, to revoke
specific a application's access
to your data.
In the two-legged
OAuth scenario,
you typically have an installed
OpenSocial application
that sits inside a container.
And that installed
application--
when you go through the process
of installing the app,
um, you're basically
granting access
for that app to access
your social data.
So then that app developer
on the networks
that support this can then go
and get a two-legged OAuth
consumer token
and consumer secret
which then they can use
to access any of the data
that--for each of the users
who have installed
this application
and granted access.
Access is generally revoked
for these applications
at the time the user
uninstalls the application.
So because all of these examples
use three-legged OAuth,
and the REST
and RPC libraries,
I thought I'd give you
a list of the containers
which I'm aware of.
Forgive me if I-I miss some.
But these are the containers
that I'm aware of
that support
these technologies.
So three-legged OAuth
and then the REST and RPC APIs
for accessing a person
and their list of friends.
Some containers may also support
additional REST and RPC APIs
for accessing things
like activities
or application data.
So I mentioned this caveat,
the installed app identification
not secure.
Uh, hopefully the word
"not secure"
didn't scare you too much.
It doesn't scare most users,
frankly.
Uh, but apps
are typically identified
by that consumer key
and secret.
When a user goes and installs
your application
on a mobile device,
they're downloading
the application.
Savvy users could then take
that application
and run something like strings
on it to get the strings
out of the app.
And thereby, your consumer key
and secrets are compromised.
There's things that you can do
to make it
a little bit more difficult.
But you can never really
make it impossible.
So what this means is that
if you have an application
that you called "foo,"
some other application developer
could come along
and take your consumer key
and secret
and pretend to be "foo"
and actually be evil "foo"
in collecting someone's
social data.
So what we do to kind of
at least make it real,
uh, in terms of share
the correct information
with the users
and granting access
to their applications,
is to display some warnings.
Uh, and we display warnings.
And basically,
there are two ways
that we can display warnings.
There's one at the top here
just saying
that there--the web site's
registered,
uh, or the application
is registered,
but isn't sending stuff
securely.
And the other way
is, uh, a new solution,
which I think we announced,
like, last week
at the Internet Identity
Workshop.
And basically we publish
a consumer key
and a consumer secret
for any application to use.
And it's called "anonymous"
and the secret's anonymous.
Uh, and then allow them
to identify themselves
by providing an additional
extended property,
uh, in the OAuth request,
called the xoauth_displayname.
And then it produces a warning
like what's down at the bottom.
Uh, and if you can't read it,
basically,
"the application
has directed you here
claims to be" and then
that xoauth_displayname,
Photo Editor in this case,
"but we're unable to verify.
"Please make sure that you went
through a proper process
to access this application."
So usually if a user
clicks on an icon
on an application
that they trust
and a web browser pops open,
it's--it's more than likely
that the, uh, application
that they just clicked on
popped open that web browser.
But making sure
that the user is aware--
and you guys as app developers
should be aware
of how this works.
So OAuth has two basic flows
in the three-legged scenario.
Uh, we talked about web apps
and we talked about native apps.
These each have different
types of flows.
So I'm just going to go
through that here.
In a web application,
you start off on the web app.
In the native application,
you start off on a native app
running on the device.
But the next step
is always the same.
Regardless of whether
you're a web application
or you're
a native application,
you have to pop open
a web browser,
uh, and ask users
to authorize access
to your data.
And I'll repeat here.
Basically, the reason is
is that the data provider
who's hosting these APIs
can choose
to authenticate and authorize
access to their data
however they want.
It's not necessarily
a username and password.
It could be something like
a secure ID or what have you.
In practice today, most of them
are usernames and passwords.
But they don't want
their users
to be entering their username
and passwords
in any app, on any device,
or on any web site.
They want to keep that
onto their particular
application.
So there's a little bit
more trust here,
uh, when user goes over
and, you know,
sees the lock
of an SSL web page,
and sees its myspace.com,
or google.com in this case,
and that's
where they're entering
their credentials.
You could also do this flow,
uh, built inside--
in the native app case.
You could do it inside
of WebView.
I did a little bit
of experimentation with that.
Basically, you--you build
a web browser into the app.
And there's easy ways
to do that on Android
and also on iPhones.
But the real key point here
is then the user
cannot be assured
that they're entering
their credentials
into the correct place.
Whereas if you pop open
a web browser,
they upgrade their assurance.
And this is provided
that, you know,
the device or computer you have
has some sort of sandboxing
for applications.
On most desktop apps,
if you installed the app
on your desktop,
they could already have access
and, you know,
do a keylogger or something
like that.
So--but, you know,
just to basically mitigate
these problems.
Um, and then at the end here
after you authorize access
to the data, it just redirects
to where you came from.
So in the top case, it redirects
back to the other web page.
In the bottom case, it redirects
back to the native application.
Uh, in Android devices
and also iPhones,
basically, you can register
protocol handlers.
So I think
my protocol handler in here
is, like, android-
divideandconquer-socialapp://
or something like that.
And basically
as soon as I click
on the authorize access
in the OAuth flow,
it calls a URL
with that protocol
and then the Android device
knows to pop open
this application,
uh, and take the OAuth token
back from the server.
So here's an example
in the native app
of me running through that.
I have a settings dialog.
I choose my social network.
And like I said,
this can be a list
of a variety
of different networks.
In this case,
it's Google I/O.
I'm choosing to log in
to my Google account.
Um, and it pops open
a web browser.
I type in my username here.
I also type in my password.
And please, folks,
this is not my real password--
I changed my password
for recording this demo--
[laughs] but don't lock
my account out
by trying, please.
Anyway, so I log in.
And then scroll down here.
You can see the warning message
that we talked about later.
In this case, I'm actually using
consumer key and secret,
not using the anonymous
anonymous.
But I should have.
And then grant access.
Now I'm back in the application.
The application has started up
that background thread,
which goes off and retrieves
all the social data,
and the thumbnail pictures,
and that sort of thing
in the background
so that while I'm playing,
that information's
made available.
As long as I don't die
too quickly,
I won't have to wait
at the end of the game
to see the top score list.
So let's see how this code works
a little bit
when we're selecting
a network here.
The big thing is
on DialogClosed.
So after I say "yes, log in
to the network"
and the dialog box closes,
I build up
my OpenSocial client
and get
an OAuth request token.
And you can see
that Android scheme
is that, you know,
opensocial-androidwhatever://
thing that I was talking about.
Um, and then I'm telling
the Android device
to browse to a particular
web page.
An Android device knows exactly
how to browse to a web page
by pop opening--
popping up the web browser.
And that automatically happens
from then on.
Okay. So I talked a lot
about Android.
You all are probably wondering:
what about the iPhone?
Um, here is an example
of an iPhone application
using the, um,
using the Objective-C
client library.
and some iPhone sample code.
It's a native app.
I go down here
and click on "fetch friends."
And choose the social network
that I want to connect to.
Plaxo in this case,
but it could be
any of those others.
It then pops open
the web browser
and the Plaxo login page.
I know where the buttons
are located here.
So I don't have to zoom in.
But I click "allow access."
You can see there's
a similar warning message.
But then it returns back
to the application
and shows my list of friends
from Plaxo.
Um, so you can imagine here,
you know, although I didn't have
a really cool in-depth demo
for the iPhone,
the same type of application
that we showed
as a native app
for Divide and Conquer
on an Android device could also
very easily be written
on the iPhone
using this library
and using some
of the sample code
that we've provided.
But what about the future?
Um, the future is hopefully
very bright.
Uh, basically,
these demonstrations showed--
uh, there's a lot of reasons
right now
that you might want to build
a native application
to access the social data.
But the things that are coming
down the line,
uh, particularly the stuff
that Vic talked about
in the keynote with HTML 5,
the Canvas, the Database,
the App Cache, can all help you
make web applications
which are more performant
and use greater functionality
in the devices.
Uh, things like Canvas
and SVG support,
you could easily make
that Divide and Conquer game.
And there's demos out there
on the web.
You saw some stuff
in the keynote.
Um, and then you can use
the same technologies
of--of Database and App Cache
to make that application
load faster even when
the user's offline.
There's also a standard
that was kind of looped
in with some of this.
There's a W3C
geolocation APIs standard
out there to get access
to the location of a user,
uh, without using something
like Gears,
but using a standard that works
on many different platforms.
And location APIs
will be available
in the upcoming
iPhone software.
But for now, you might have
to do a little bit of a fork
depending on whether
you're supporting iPhone,
or Android,
or other devices.
Um, and then just generally
improved browser performance.
Right now it takes
a lot of time
to load up a web application
for the first time.
It has to load the web browser
into memory
and load all the code
for parsing your JavaScript,
and HTML,
and--and that sort of thing.
But that will be improved
over time.
So here's some credits
for the closed caption--
or closed captioned--
CC means closed captioned,
apparently, to me today.
Creative Commons-licensed
photos.
So thank you very much
for Flickr
for making it easy
to find these.
Uh, and thank you
for all these photographers
for taking the pictures.
And now it's time
for questions.
You can feel free
to come to the microphones
like I mentioned earlier,
or you can post your questions
at the URL below
on Google Moderator.
And I'll start off by taking
some microphone questions.
Um, over there.
man: Thank you
for a good presentation.
I appreciate it.
Um, my question
is in regards
to the push
versus the pull model.
Um, and I'm interested
in a model
where events are pushed
from the server
to the web application
without the user having
to manually click on something
in order for their view
to update
or to go fetch
the latest information.
But that information
is seamlessly updated
to those web clients.
Boyd: Okay.
Um, so I'm not aware
of anything right now
which really does
the push model that well.
You could use protocols
like XMTP
or something like that,
uh, or even SMS to do pushes
from providers
like MySpace, or Plaxo,
or whatever.
They haven't implemented
any of that
as far as I'm aware
to push that out
in an efficient way
to the devices.
You are seeing though
some things--
technologies coming out
to make pool
a lot more efficient.
Uh, I don't know
when the session was or is.
I should probably know this.
But there's a YouTube session
talking about their
activity stream APIs.
And they talk
about the SUP protocol.
I think it's Simple Update
Protocol.
And basically,
it was a protocol developed
to get--if you have a lot
of different users,
to get--to pull down a list
of all the users,
which have updated content.
So basically you get hashes
of all their user IDs.
And you can do one pull every,
say, like, you know, two minutes
or something like that,
and get a list
of all your users
that have had
their content changed.
And that's kind of an efficient
way to do the--the pool stuff.
But I'm not aware
if it's actually supported
by any OpenSocial
containers yet.
But we'll certainly take that
into advisement.
Um, and you're welcome
as is everyone else here
to participate
in the OpenSocial spec process
and put forth ideas
like that.
Uh, and the way
this spec process works,
it's an online group.
Everyone's invited to join,
uh, proposals.
This process keeps on getting
modified a little bit
based off of experiences we've
had with previous versions.
But, uh, proposals
basically right now
take five positive votes
to get
into the specification.
Uh, and then you do
a prototype.
And as long as you have
no negative votes,
it can get
into the specification.
So we encourage everyone
to be involved with OpenSocial.
And if there's, you know,
a real strong need
for something like that,
go to this spec group,
uh, and propose it,
and see what the containers
have to say 'cause both
containers and app developers
actively participate
in that.
Next, I'm going to open up
the Moderator here.
First of all, you guys
can look at my dog.
Uh, and...
So the first question here
is "Where could we get
the sample code
for the examples
that you presented?"
So the OpenSocial
Java client library
has built into it
an Android sample
not quite as intricate
as the example
that I presented,
but does have
an Android sample.
The Objective-C client library
for OpenSocial--
if you just search for
OpenSocial client libraries,
you'll find all of this--
the Objective-C one
has the iPhone samples.
The Divide and Conquer app
and the web application
that I worked on,
basically, the code
was written up
through a couple days ago.
And I haven't gone in through
the full, like, open source
releasing process and, um,
actually cleaned up all the code
other than the slides
that I presented.
So those will be online
and open source shortly.
And you'll find all of that
mentioned
on the OpenSocial blog.
So sorry I don't have that
for you today.
Take another in-person one.
man: Apologize
for a second question.
Um, where do you see
the wave--
Google Wave app or platform,
uh, in regards to OpenSocial
in looking forward?
Boyd: Um, I can state
my personal comments on this
and my personal beliefs.
I don't--I don't have
the official word on that.
I mean, uh, basically,
waves are very social things.
Uh, they currently expose
some APIs in Wave
that are like the social APIs
in OpenSocial.
So there's the notion of who's
currently participating,
who overall is participating--
think of, like, the profile
and the friends--
um, and they certainly have
the notion of activities.
So I would hope
as--as they, you know, adopt
OpenSocial standards,
that they would also adopt
the REST and RPC APIs,
which would allow you
to do many things like this.
But keep in mind, there is
a totally different context
with Wave than there is,
uh, with traditional
social network apps.
So, um, but that's--
that's all I can say.
And that's, again,
my personal opinion,
not, uh,
not the official word.
man: Yeah. Thank you.
Boyd: Let me just go back
to one question from here.
"What did I use to record
those demo videos?"
Snapz Pro, um, is an application
I downloaded, like,
a couple years ago
and paid for.
It's an--a shareware app.
Use it for free for 30 days.
It's really cool.
Um, and Keynote is amazing
at embedding video.
So this is the first time
I've actually done demo videos
like that.
And I hope you guys liked it.
It made it a little bit easier
and less chance
that the demo would crash.
Um...
Thanks.
And I guess we'll take
an in-person question now.
man: I was going to say
one thing is, uh,
Screenflow is another
great program
to, uh, to capture, uh, web in--
or, uh, screencasts from.
Um, I was actually--
I just finished writing
a Facebook connect application
on the iPhone.
And, uh, I don't think
a whole lot
about, you know,
the social network
that must bot--not be named.
But they've done
a good job
of making the flow
on the device
very straightforward
and nowhere near as disruptive
as, you know, it looks like
to jump out to another browser.
Um, I've--I was one
of the early adopters of OAuth.
I've done--I've done
AuthSub before that.
And on the web,
it's a great environment
and it's--
it's a very nice flow.
Are there plans to build
a set of client libraries
that we can use
on these devices?
I mean, there's a finite
number of them right now.
There's, like, you know,
four or five of them.
And if you supported that,
uh, I think the user experience
would be dramatically better.
Boyd: So we don't have
direct plans.
Uh, I mean,
there is a sample code.
We could build, you know,
better client libraries.
I don't know of any plans
to do that right now.
Um, to answer your question
about, like,
the Face connect model
versus what we showed here,
it's--basically,
it's always a question
of--of balancing user privacy
and, uh, security
with user interface
and user interaction.
Um, and in the case
of the Facebook connect model,
they chose to allow,
uh, app developers to display
what is essentially,
like, a WebView
within their application,
uh, that they've written
and the user enters
their credentials
directly in the application.
That's not something
that I have known
that, uh, OpenSocial networks,
uh, have been comfortable with.
Um, but, you know,
it may happen.
Um, you know, personally,
I like to enter my credentials
in a place that I know
is--is the actual web browser
in the device
with the SSL icon.
But I understand
that a lot of users,
um, could care less.
But--so it's--it's just
making that balance.
Um, and, you know, right now,
it's up for,
you know, we have
some social networks.
I doubt that we'll be
promoting that as Google.
But, uh, you know,
there's all sorts
of other social networks
around there too
that were in that list
and other OpenSocial containers
that may choose
to--to balance that equation
somewhere else along the line.
Um, I don't know
where it would be.
So...
"How to aggregate users
removing redundant ones
"across different
social networks--
"Orkut, MySpace,
and maybe Facebook
representing one single user
on the mobile app client?"
Uh, I mean, there's certainly
an opportunity here,
at least for, you know,
an open platform like Android,
to develop an application
which aggregated that
and opened up some services
for individual third-party apps
to hook into.
I haven't seen
one of those yet.
But there--there's definitely
an opportunity for that.
No other in-person questions.
So the last question...
"Is the level of data access
the same for two-legged OAuth
and three-legged OAuth?"
Um, the actual standard
doesn't really define
what level of access
you'll have.
That's up to the individual
providers
that are making these APIs
available.
Uh, in practice, I think
the--the data is the same
that I've seen.
Um, you know, what acc--
what data you have access to
with two-legged
versus three-legged OAuth.
But a provider could choose
to provide
different levels of access.
And that's all the questions
I have here.
Uh, is there any more
in person?
Okay. Thank you very much.